[Music]
thank you so much for having me hey I
had to change my nametag earlier just
because I'm no longer actually at
Netflix so I've been it I was at Netflix
for about four years and then about
eight months ago I left Netflix and
joined a stealth mode startup to do some
continuing R&D based on this work as
well as trying to turn it into a more
scalable product and service that
connect it so that not only Netflix can
benefit from the estimating
incrementality and sort of bringing
these things together but also hopefully
the rest of the world will be able to do
it cuz it's kind of hard to build these
things at least I found it was hard to
build them and I want to make it easier
for everybody else to to benefit from
them as well so so first off just by the
by a show of hands who here knows what
the word incrementality means or has
heard it before okay so we've got like
few people who here really loves
econometrics and how about machine
learning who said taken a stab at
machine learning off and on okay so this
talk is going to be kind of a blend of
these of these three three main ideas
put together in a practical application
as we start thinking about sort of
information platforms and sort of
algorithmic game theory that those types
of concepts what we're primarily going
to be applying this in a setting where
you're trying to estimate a best
response function so you're basically
trying to write down an algorithm that
is going to give you the the way to make
a decision before it for your algorithm
so let's get into the end of the details
here so give you guys a little bit of
background
hopefully this thing's working great all
right so it's it's worth noting that it
takes a lot of people to do this type of
research at a company you need to have
people like management to give you the
out of the freedom and finances to make
it happen you need people to actually
then go and execute the actual work as
well so like that this write work is not
just me it represents a whole bunch of
people all working together and I'm
really grateful for those partnerships
so first off why does incrementality
matter I think it's helpful to even
understand what incrementality is
and why it might matter especially in
the world of advertising but also in
many other applications as well so for
example when I first joined Yahoo ten
years ago 11 I guess it's been a while
now I kept seeing plots that looked like
this where we would before an ad it was
exposed people would you know people
would be engaging in an activity at some
baseline right I know there'd be a giant
spike on the day of ad exposure so you
know it looks like the ads are having a
huge effect and everybody in the
marketing departments loving this across
you know you know who loves it because
they're selling a lot of advertising and
then and then you sort of you start
thinking about it well you know ad
exposures happening on that day maybe we
should just run run an experiment just
to make sure that things are what what
you think we think they are well it
turns out that when you run an
experiment you get a control group that
looks like that so there's a gigantic
spike that happens on the same day as a
bad exposure even when you showed an ad
that was completely irrelevant to the
outcome so what's going on here well we
called this activity bias this is
essentially that is there's a
contemporaneous correlation that when
you go online today and you start
browsing you're gonna see some ads and
what else are you gonna do when you go
online today you're gonna buy some stuff
why weren't you online yesterday maybe
you're on vacation when you weren't when
you're on vacation you weren't buying
stuff you were doing other things you
know you weren't browsing the web and so
inadvertently that these types of plots
end up creating a spurious correlation
so in econometrics we call this spurious
regression this is just trying to
correlate collinear things that move
both move over time contemporaneous
correlations and it's just another form
of omitted variable bias or in dodging a
T so obviously this is a problem so in
the in the world of a defectiveness
around this time in 2008 that the this
this came out in the Harvard Business
Review essentially saying that it's
really easy to measure the effective ads
because you just need to compare online
purchases by those who have seen the ad
and those who have not seen the ad and I
so some some other economists who worked
at eBay for a little while they thought
that quote was crazy as well so what
what they found is is that when when you
set up these these these ads for eBay
you know you have links here that are if
you're paying to get clicks on and down
here you have links that you're not
paying to get clicks on so you don't you
don't have to pay for those and
similarly you'd have like Macy's would
advertise on the keyword Macy's so when
you type in the word the word Macy's
where do you think people are trying to
go Macy's the types of people who don't
type in the the keyword Macy's where do
you think they're trying to go not
Macy's so it shouldn't be surprising
that the people who type in the keyword
Macy's and see the ad are going to
convert at a different rate so
regardless of the presence or absence of
that ad so this is the this is the
foundation of in dodging 80 that the
actual treatment itself is correlated
with the error that these people are
just different and you haven't
controlled for that so when you run an
a/b test here's the man himself I'm gay
I'm actually giving a talk on your
research instead of mine
no but so this work was really great and
what Stephen and others were able to
show is that when when you turned off
the advertising that you see a kind of a
direct substitution between those
organic clicks and the sponsored clicks
and they then ran another test on Google
to see if the effect also held and sure
enough it did so what what you worry
about is when these when these what
these substitution effects happen is are
you actually losing something as a
result and this is a logarithmic
logarithmic scale so it actually turns
out that roughly there's approximately
perfect substitution in both of these
cases so people were trying to get the
Macy's they got to make these people try
to get it trying to get to eBay there
they got to eBay when you start looking
at some of the the sort of the classical
correlational metrics that a marketers
are using in order to determine the
effectiveness of a campaign there's a
couple measurements here and we have we
have one measurement which is this blue
line which shows a clear drop so this
ends up being the post click or or these
are these are what are called the
attributed sales so these are like post
view
or post click type conversions and as a
result when you turn off advertising
what happens you have fewer
opportunities to correlate sales to
marketing but what you what you look
when you compare a test and control
group well at the moment when they
turned off all the ads you don't really
see any mark market decrease in the
actual purchase behavior among the
customers
and over here there's another analysis
that that shows have shows that there's
essentially no effect on sales that when
you choose to market all right so what
what they were able to show first off
they they didn't call this paper
Howie Bey was throwing away lots and
lots of money by advertising and
effectively what they know things said
titled the paper is consumer
heterogeneity and paid search
effectiveness and and essentially what
they were able to find is that yes there
was a lot of money being wasted because
the the estimation strategy for figuring
out how effective the advertising was
was was was imperfect but what they were
able to show is that there actually were
some pockets of incrementality or causal
effect of advertising happening and
among the among the subpopulations so it
gave an opportunity set up arbitrage so
they were able to then change the
direction that they were spending from
do you know blanketing a lot of people
that didn't need to that didn't need
that advertising to moving it into more
efficient more efficient opportunities
and so that's really sort of what what
we hope to do with the increment with
this incrementality bidding work so
essentially the the ideal experiment
when you set up a testing control group
is to be able to track the people who
are going to see the netflix IDI who
actually see the Netflix ID you want to
be able to compare them to the people
who would have seen the Netflix at and
in in these auction environments where
you're submitting a bid in to an auction
to win an advertisement you don't
necessarily get control over the the all
the users in the control group unless
you actually choose to purchase this ad
but that costs a lot of money so there's
a lot of reasons why you want to what
you want to avoid that avoid having to
spend the money and so then another
paper we came up with this idea called
ghost ads where you're able to sort of
simulate the auction and learn
whether the weather an experiment would
have won and so if you want to learn
about that it's you know I think it's a
great paper so but but essentially what
we're trying to do is estimate the
causal effect of an ad within
criminality so we have in a control
group you're gonna see other advertisers
ads you're still going to visit the web
pages
you're gonna browse and and then in the
treatment group instead of seeing the
other advertiser's ad you're gonna see
perhaps this sporting good retailers ad
and that will cause sales to go up by
$100,000 so what we can we can infer
from this just like we would in any sort
of a standard experiment is that we have
an increase in sales and because we had
random assignment we've now solved this
in dodging ad problem or this bias
problem that was playing us at the
beginning and that we now have those
comparable groups so the nice thing to
note here is that it helps us estimate
what the what the actual true effect was
and translate it into business metrics
that such as how much we should how much
how much revenue we're getting per
thousand impressions which is then what
the marketers are gonna use to submit
bids into these auctions
but we don't just want to know whether
the ads were ineffective as in Steve's
case we don't just want to know is that
after the fact we spent all this money
was it worth it that's not as helpful as
as knowing well we've spent this money
where was it more worth it versus where
what was it less so perhaps we have this
group of outdoor enthusiasts there they
account for 80 percent of the increase
and then 20 percent of the increase is
coming from the not outdoor enthusiasts
for the sporting goods retailer and what
this allows us to do then is to take the
number of impressions that we're shown
here and translate these into actual
willingness to pay or a maximum value so
in essence we should never be willing to
bid more than six dollars per thousand
impressions if this is the magnitude of
increment of incrementality that we're
getting so some basic arithmetic here
but we want to do is take this idea of
outdoor enthusiasts and not outdoor
enthusiasts and turn it into a term
basically turn it into a classical
machine learning algorithm where we're
today you can go and buy buy media based
off of impressions so
you know pay a certain certain amount
per impression or you pay-per-click or
you pay per attributed conversion sort
of a conversion that happens after an
impression so as we've seen some of
those metrics are potentially subject to
some of these other critiques where you
can end up spending 50 million dollars
and beginning a - let's say 80% ROI on
that and not know it just because you're
maximizing in some sense maximizing the
wrong objective so we want to do is
figure out how to maximize maximize the
yield here against against the spend
that we are going to so that's really
what well but what we need to do but we
need to be able to estimating from
mentality with a more scalable model
that fits within the standard frameworks
like this type of model is an a/b test
like a user level a/b test but the
reality of advertising is that you don't
get to show a person one ad use and
usually you don't get to control the
opportunities because they're the ones
that are controlling the opportunities
they're visiting they're browsing
they're they're engaging in ways that
you know you can't like handcuff
somebody to a computer and type and
force them to visit a particular webpage
in order to have see that one ad and
then force them to look at it as well
like all of these all these types of
differences make it really hard to
actually differentiate between the
people who are going to see the ad
versus those who would have seen the ad
and and so we need to set it up in a
framework that's that's gonna allow us
to estimate it not just for outdoor
enthusiasts the type of people but also
maybe for the type of treatment so for
perhaps we want to estimate different ad
sizes we want to estimate different you
know different characteristics of the ad
just like if you were you know trying to
treat someone with medication you'd want
to control maybe the dose intensity and
you want to understand how the response
is going to vary or how the health
response might very well with that
alright so so how are we gonna do that
well it helps to understand sort of the
basics of causal of causal inference so
who here has heard of directed acyclic
graphs DAGs
okay all right great well enough people
that maybe I'll just breeze through this
real quick so in essence what we're what
we're going to do is we're going to run
an experiment here that is going to vary
the amount of
exposure so we're gonna set up an a/b
test but not a user level a/b test we're
gonna set up a in some sense a treatment
level a a B test that allows us to vary
this in a way that's uncorrelated with
all of these other confounders that my
tent that are correlate with purchases
so like this is did you type in Macy's
and what we're gonna do is be able to
then brand 'm randomize whether you see
that at or not maybe how high we bid and
as a result we'll feel or maybe what
subpopulation maybe even what creative
we put in it so we'll be able to do all
that and then we'll see how that
influences purchases so in the world of
advertising there's also some of the
worst forms of in dodging eighty that
crop up one of them is known as as
negative targeting so for Netflix we
might like to show ads to people in
order to get them to sign up for for for
the service and you know what but if but
as soon as you've signed up we want to
stop showing you ads because we don't
maybe maybe we don't want to bother you
or maybe it just costs money and and if
we've achieved what we the the goal of
you know getting someone to sign up then
we don't need to spend that money
anymore or maybe half of the population
that's already signed out so one of the
challenges here is that if people are if
people have signed up and then that
influence is whether or not you're you
see an ad what you'll find is that we
start showing ads all the people who
haven't signed up and depending on how
you analyze this data you have to be
careful because you can you can sort of
get your you know get your data crossed
in that in that the people who are
signing up aren't seeing ads so we show
fewer ads to the people who have not
signed up and this actually induces a
negative correlation between ad exposure
and signing up so okay so the yeah
you've got to be careful with these
things alright so so in the end we're
gonna set up we have a sort of a simple
heterogeneous treatment effects model so
we're gonna have an outcome wide for a
user I and we're going to have a
treatment X or treatment intensity X
with user I and we're going to model the
baseline which is your likelihood of
purchasing or signing up and then we'll
have
an error term sort of a standard
econometrics model so within essentially
what we're trying to estimate is Delta Y
which is the the incremental effect or
the causal effect of showing an ad by
computing the difference in expectations
out that's just this coefficient if we
want ahead our genius treatment effects
we just need to interact treatment with
with other characteristics and then we
need to make sure we have a baseline
that's also sort of rich and
heterogeneous any questions at this
point so so you know as I said these are
going to be things like ad size maybe
the country that the persons from etc
yeah so the almost always when you have
a piece of information from the so when
you have a bid request that comes in or
an opportunity to show an ad or to
purchase an ad there will be a whole
bunch of information that's embedded in
there so it will it will have all the
information about the ad size the
website it's it's from usually there'll
be like a cookie identifier of some sort
and then and then to the extent that
there's other information for example to
know whether or not you want to buy the
ad or not maybe maybe for Netflix it was
you have to you have to be able to lend
link that user identifier to know that
that person's already a member so you
know there's there some some offline
data processes that bring additional
that enriched the or augment the date
this bid request with additional
information
the so in the Netflix subscriber system
sure yes yeah yeah so for the most part
you you have a database that allows you
to immediately look up before you take
an action so so yes the there is some
sort of partitioning that's done
beforehand okay so so this type of model
is something like the models that we
that I showed right at the beginning
that are that are potentially fraught
with bias and can lead you to to make
those spurious correlations that people
who see an ad on the day that they see
an ad are gonna are going to have you
know they're more likely more likely to
see an ad but they're also more likely
to convert but in a spurious way so in
order to avoid this we're going to set
up a framework using instrumental
variables so who here is heard of two
stage least squares or instrumental
variables wow that's a lot okay so the
the basic principles of this model is
that we're going to use we're gonna set
up the randomization information so when
we've actually injected randomization
we're going to put that information into
our variable Z and it'll allow us to
form to create a form of least squares
estimation that allows us to then
retrieve a causal effect under a bunch
of assumptions and so the the difference
between classical sort of econometric
standard Bob's are using observational
data with instrumental variables so that
usually with an instrumental variable
you have to believe something so you
have to you have to there's a bunch of
assumptions and you have to satisfy
those assumptions and then when you when
you go to an econometrics apply to
econometrics seminar there's going to be
at least 30 minutes out of the 75
minutes is almost always going to be
dedicated to people hassling you about
whether they believe your instrument or
not whether they think you have a quasi
randomization that it that is worth
looking at and now sort of let's say 10
or 15 years from when I was sort of
going through a lot of this in grad
school now they're they've gotten even
more sophisticated and now it's about
whether that population where that
randomization was happening is in fact
representative of the more broader
population so in other words you've
estimated a what's known as a local
average treatment effect or something to
that that tune and then we now
understand that it's
like a weighted average of a bunch of
people that happen to have some little
bit of randomization in that population
so the beautiful thing about being in
industry and working on an application
is that I can do two things I can shut
down that 30 minutes and I can stead use
it or not use it like today I can
instead just say look we built
randomization so I've satisfied the
first assumption and then the second
assumption is I just need to make sure
that when I randomize something it
actually changes something and I can
just sort of show you that so so in this
case wow it's not just unique to
industry but we can do it at a scale for
this type of problem that we can solve
it so I don't know what what other
applications are you are you you you do
but in a in a lot of the the
observational sort of whenever you're
trying to a causal inference within
observational data in many cases you
don't have a form of engineered
randomization so if you're doing field
experiments yeah yeah yeah yeah you
certainly have that so like especially
in the development literature it's
plenty of that and over the last decade
there's been more and more field
experiments so for sure yeah we worried
that your randomization affects
different populations differently
because the other bidders are bidding
differently on those populations yes so
so then a that is a great question so
that so the question is when you
introduce different forms of random is
it randomization it's going to change
which subpopulations maybe you're able
to treat so in this case we're going to
focus on just estimating the the
treatment effect that is internally
valid so the pot the people that we do
in with the forms of randomization that
we do in and then there's this question
of generalizability that when you've
estimated those treatment effects if now
you go and change the algorithm how will
that change the the subpopulations that
you're able to show ads to or maybe
there's an even more abstract question
which is what is the treatment effect
what is the average treatment effect on
all the people that you weren't able to
treat in general for for industry
applications we're less interested in
that one just because if we can't treat
them we can't treat them or if you can't
treat them economically then you
then there's no point in training them
but there's plenty of other applications
where those are interesting concepts
okay all right so so if we want to do
heterogeneous treatment effects in an
instrumental variable framework we can
do that as well if we've engineered a
randomization then we can just create
interactions with our randomization and
if it's a it's an event level
randomization it turns out it's
independent of everything you can
interact it with everything and this
allows you to create you know models
that perhaps have like 10,000 endogenous
right-hand side variables that you're
you know components of the treatment and
then you can construct the corresponding
you know 10,000 instrumental variables
so we sort of push into a realm that
that where we have enough randomization
and we have enough variables maybe we
even want to push this further until
like million feature regressions those
are the types of things you can then do
using some of the machine learning tools
so this is going to be the workhorse
this is in some sense the the core the
core concept that we're going to work
with but we need to take this out of a
world where we don't have time so
there's a there's a handful of
differences in industry that we really
have to address that haven't typically
been addressed in the academic
literature for experimentation at least
within the add effectiveness literature
so alright so what are a couple of
challenges that we have to face well in
industry in sort of these real-time
bidding auctions where we're showing
display ads or banner ads to people
there's you're dealing with over 10
billion auctions per day so there's just
like a huge amount of data coming in
you're you're looking at estimating
models maybe have a billion users or
approximate the the effect on a billion
users or you know billion identifiers
you have you know some of these
challenges of like inexpensive ad
impressions means that there's probably
not a large signal if there was a large
signal they'd be worth more people don't
pay a lot of attention to them usually
have sparse conversions so there's not a
lot of a lot of outcome data coming and
another challenge is that you have a
continuous stream of data so you have to
you're constantly having to make
decisions while more data is coming in
and perhaps even adapt to the
marketplace conditions
you have things like high dimensionality
because the characteristics of the ads
are rich and then you have this problem
of correlation causation which is what
we're gonna season for and then you know
there's some of these other challenges
of trying to get people to want to run
experiments so like when I think about
why working in ad tech is interesting
it's not because I love showing people
ads who here loves to see ads I mean
like yeah all right we got Dean Dean
loves looking at ads oh yeah I am not
you know I don't I got into ad tech
because I found that it was a really
interesting rich environment that had
this type of scale and this and these
types of challenges to take on and and I
feel like if we can solve some of these
you know rich heterogeneous treatment
effect problems in ad tech wet with us
at the scale that they are then it
should be relatively easy to sort of
take some of those things that we've
learned and apply them to a broad set of
other applications and you know that's
kind of what we found at Netflix all
right so there's a I'm gonna focus on
these sort of three problems and and how
am i doing on time do I saw like 15
minutes okay so we've got you know down
sampling that is one way to solve this
solve the some of the data volume issues
we want to do it in an informational
efficient way we're gonna use some
continuous time modeling to address the
fact that that that we don't have to
worry about feedback or in dodging ad on
human decision timescale so typically if
you have if you have a bureaucrat that
is creating a policy then usually
there's like a clear event you know you
can run event studies where you have
like a change in the law before and
after in the case of real-time bidding
you have potentially these types of
feedback where as soon as you have
signed up for Netflix within
milliseconds we can suppress ads and so
you you have this type of feedback that
can happen on that time scale and it
turns out if your bucketing by day all
of your data then you know you're gonna
miss out on your basically you're gonna
create this opportunity for
contemporaneous correlations that will
introduce bias so we want to have a
continuous time model to do that and
finally you know if I time permits all
I'll just briefly mention some of the
ideas about house
cause a correction yes cool stats how do
you implement it goes down as a critter
yeah so so nor so I'll have one one
picture that I'll show for that okay
alright so in continuous-time first off
we need to understand maybe what the
shape of an a defect looks like in
continuous-time so here's a Super Bowl
commercials the the green bar that you
can't really see is when the ad what
happened and then the spikes kind of
look like this where there's a big spike
and and sort of people visiting a
website or issuing queries for that
brand in the time and following the ad
similarly in display advertising this is
this is another one of those spurious
correlations where this is the histogram
of searches for Macy's say following an
ad exposure and it on the within the
first 10 minutes you have a whole bunch
of people searching for Macy's problem
is is you also have a whole bunch of
people searching for Craigslist right
after seeing an ad for Macy's so again
we have this sort of spurious
correlation problem where or what ends
up happening is that people are just
actively doing stuff like when you when
you see an ad that means you're about to
do something else you know type in a
search that's just what happens in life
so it turns out though that when you set
up an experiment you can also see that
that the ad effects themselves tend to
spike so the green bar represents the
amount of add effect over and above the
blue bars which which show the baseline
you're able to see that that the ad
effects are in fact sort of do spike in
this way so we want to have we want a
model that effects the spike in this way
so perhaps we're going to set up we're
going to use a kernel in this case an
exponential kernel to model this effect
and we can if you want if you say I
don't like that shape well then I'll
just we'll just add another shape to it
and we'll do a mixture of kernels so
that maybe it looks more like an ad
effect that you're you know you think
ads do look more like and you know the
nice thing about this is parametrized in
a way that allows us to actually
estimate those mixing coefficients and
then you'll be able to just estimate
what that shape looks like so this is
kind of like semi-parametric depending
on how rigorous you want to get about
terminology so so then maybe either it's
not just one ad but there's another ad
we then stacked those on top if we want
to
we you know maybe there's there's a
second ad and we're just going to say
that they're additively separable at
this point then maybe we add another ad
we also we also maybe change the size
and the shapes and and you know we can
have a we can actually as we start
adding more and more features to our
model if they don't just the the effects
don't just vary by user over time or by
the impression but maybe also by
impression characteristics so maybe
different ad sizes are you know there's
ad size changes how big the curves are
maybe even changes the shape and the
dynamics and so what we want to do is be
able to estimate a model that has all of
these types of that it can recover these
dynamic treatment effect curves and why
do we want to do that well the main
reason why we went down this Avenue is
that it turns out that if that a lot of
the approaches in the past that analyzed
in a user level experiment over say four
weeks ends up integrating all of the
conversions over those entire four weeks
but if the ad effects only last one day
you know essentially in terms of the the
the lion's share of the effect then
you're at you're you're increasing your
noise potentially by a factor of twenty
eight over what you otherwise could do
and so this is a way to buy a
substantial amount of power by
restricting the window and modeling that
those are those response curves yes so
could there be just you know additive
effect going on there that it's that
third addict just nails me or is ad
number three the one that really
as the most bang for buck all right so
there's there's actually sort of two
pieces to answer that question
one is there's nothing that prevents us
from modeling ad threes shape as a
function of it being the third ad as
opposed to the first in the second
there's a more there's more difficult
dynamic optimization problem which says
how do I should I should I throw away
money on the first two ads because I
know that's where my payouts can it be
is on the third ad we're not going to
try to solve that problem but if you
have a vest response function that tells
you how effective first ad second ads
and third ads are then you can start
asking about these dynamic strategies
you can start simulating them does that
answer the question
all right so so you know in some sense
there's this concept called multi-touch
attribution which is how much of the
effect goes how much of an effect of an
ad or sorry how much of the effect so
when someone buys makes a purchase or
when someone signs up for Netflix how
much credit should we give to each one
of the impressions or how much credit
should we give to a particular publisher
for generating these these conversions
and and so the the challenge is is that
this is what usually what you get to
observe over time you get to observe
something like a histogram a
continuous-time histogram of when
conversions happened over time you know
the you know the conversion doesn't show
up and say hey you know I I was caused
by the ad of course or I wasn't caused
by the ad I'm a baseline conversion I
wish it did then I wouldn't have to do
any of this work and we just the problem
would be solved but the nice thing about
the model is that it allows us to
actually estimate these things so we
have we can construct what we call an
increment allottee share so in this case
with the model we're able to estimate
the baseline which we can which we do
through the the experiment versus the
incremental effect which we do by
modeling the dynamics of the treatment
effect and so what we estimator is that
this conversion had a 70% probability of
being caused by the ads and a 30%
probability of not being caused by the
yet
you can you sort of get with that type
of information also it turns out that
the value of the ad is actually just the
area of the curve so it's the integral
it's it's you integrate over time the
amount of ink the the change in the
probability of an expected conversion
over time and that's like a really nice
characteristic because then it turns out
that in a real time bidding scenario
this means that all we have to do is
compute an inner product and because you
have to be able to respond with a bid
within you have to be able to compute
your bid say on the order of 20
milliseconds or less it's very helpful
to use very simple functions and so this
allows us to just use a simple inner
product estimate this effect so we
didn't have to do any like numerical
integration or minimization or MCMC or
you know whatever whatever exciting
things you but you normally would like
to use all right so it also allows us to
break down the effect into the
components I think I have another plot
that's makes it clear okay so the first
ad in this case would be responsible for
39% and expectation 31% for the second
ad 0% for the third because it hasn't
happened yet and and then in this case
we have 30% for the baseline right so if
you have another conversion we can do
the exact same decomposition so this is
a nice thing that allows us to sort of
accumulate all of the effects for the
against many conversions of a given ad
impression so in this case we can add
the first effect to the second effect
and then we would say that the expected
number of conversions that this this
impression drove is just 39% plus 6% or
so just this sort of additive separable
tea makes accounting very nice it when
it when it comes time to bring your
answers together so that so that you
have multi
a centrally the same answer either same
answer and expectation or the same
answer numerically so we can either we
can either integrate up a all the users
conversions where we've estimated the
increment allottee share or we can
integrate it up across all the ad
impressions or we can the impressions
and their conversion components or we
can just sum up all the total effects of
the impressions so this is really nice
for if you're building a sequel database
and need to be able to query it really
quickly so that so that people who are
running ad campaigns can know how
effective the ads are so they can that
they can make decisions all right
so I'm gonna so this is kind of the nice
plot that allows you to see that that
you can estimate both the the shares as
the conversions are observed as well as
the residual amortized component of the
ad that says how much how much
incrementality do you still expect to
observe so when you're building a system
you need to be thinking about this so
that you can so that you don't have like
when someone turns on a campaign it
doesn't say hey there's no
incrementality and we don't expect any
income tell you what you want to be able
to show them is here's the a
incrementality we've observed so far and
here's the amount we still expect to
observe so that they can make a decision
that says all right well should I change
things yet or should I just be patient
and see how the realizations turn out
and there's more stability yes I'm
having really large time lags
between the startup money you are yeah
so all that really depends on how
precise your estimation is so if it
turns out that there's a really strong
signal to noise they don't need to be
they don't need to differ at all
if it turns out that that your
signal-to-noise is weak like it really
is then you need to start thinking about
how do you how do you introduce
randomization in order to dynamically
estimate these effects if you're going
to estimate it using instrumental
variables
you're not estimating instrument if
you're not using instrumental variables
then then it just changes the variance
and you just estimate the regression and
you and if you have a way to to change
that lag that's great but in typically
we wouldn't have this we don't have the
ability to change it other than just not
buying the add question all right so let
me just skip ahead to the sort of the
last last two ideas that I wanted to
just go into which is there was a ghost
bid question
all right so okay so so in the case of
all right so in the case so so ghost
adds normally we would just say alright
so suppose we have this baseline the
real world the baseline is not constant
its diets dynamic when you visit rotten
tomatoes to see to look up you know a
new show may be bird bucks and you're
trying to figure out whether you want to
watch it and then you see a Netflix ad
then the question is that do you go sign
up for Netflix because you were on the
rotten tomatoes page or do you sign up
for Netflix because there was a Netflix
ad on the Rotten Tomatoes page there's a
simultaneity problem and the only way we
can get around that is by randomly
putting that ad on that page or not and
so we're able to do that but but we
don't get to we don't get 100% control
over whether we put that out on that
page or not unless we want to bid
astronomical amounts and and even then
sometimes you still don't win so so you
know this would be the ideal world where
we can where either random as it where
either ad exposure is effectively random
which it's not random non-compliance
this is more typical of what would
happen is that when we don't win versus
when we do win the baseline moves up and
down on us so the solution to this is
something we call it ghost bids which is
that you know if we're able to randomize
its presence or not then we get to
compare it but but what we end up using
an instrumental variables framework is
that we're gonna we're gonna randomly
change whether we win or not by chain
but we don't get a hundred percent
control over it so we're able to
estimate is the curve when we win sort
of or we able to estimate this curve
which is that when we win 50 percent of
the time and then we can inflate it to
know how big the treatment effect is
just like happens in a in the lay
framework yes you know the context of
trying to estimate the best response in
these old
do you know whether truthful bidding is
in fact the best response in these
auctions so now that the second price
well first off in dynamic second price
auctions the answer is almost always no
anyway
in static single-shot second price
auctions then sort of you know people
like to think about that truthful
bidding is the right thing to do in
front now that over the last summer
pretty much everything is moved to first
price at least in terms of the open RTV
ecosystem and so as a result now that
definitely you should be bid shading in
some way and it and that introduces a
complete a different challenge so I'd
say that there's two parts of the market
there's estimating your your valuation
function your willingness to pay and
then there's a dynamic strategy problem
of figuring out given evaluation now
what should my bid be and so for the
most part we're just trying to nail the
first question and then then the game
that you play with that valuation
function knowingly in some sense you
know the payoff matrix now you can then
start to ask the questions of now let's
put all the game structure on top of it
because people don't change the bids
very often and presumably it increases
revenue thank you like in the short run
if you just suddenly you know run an a/b
test for two weeks you're gonna see
there's a huge revenue increase in in
practice that's probably not that silly
the the actual real reason is that is
that it's a hard problem and usually if
you put a first price in you're able to
in essence it's it's like put it
simplifies the reserve pricing problem
and there's probably a couple other
reasons why that I'm ignorant
yes there was one other question yeah
yes so you can do that sorry there's
nothing that prevents you from including
the interaction exactly so yeah so if we
wanted to know what's the effect of the
third ad we might want to say well that
that's basically like interacting an ad
that has been preceded by two ads as
well yeah so so you can enrich the model
the the question of how much you can
enrich it really comes down to
signal-to-noise and you know that's
that's where the machine learning comes
in because it allows you to then do
model selection regularization and clean
up all of this you know basically we've
added those ijk features towels there
was another towel in there because of
the kernels and then it allows us to
sort of clean up maybe like you know
take fifty thousand features and then
prune it down to maybe the five thousand
that actually matter all right so let me
conclude with this concept called the
the Hausman color correction choice do I
have like two minutes three minutes okay
all right so who here is familiar with
let's see okay let's just get that okay
so who here has heard of the Hausman
test Hausman woot Durbin depends on who
who you this school of thought you agree
with so in the world of econometrics
there's this concept of the house being
causal sorry the Hausman test which
basically compares a model that you
believe in but is noisier than you want
it to be but with a model that you that
you that you know might be wrong but you
really want to use it because because it
gives you a more precise answer maybe
gave you a statistically significant
result and so the housing test allows us
to to figure out in a principled way how
to select between these two models based
off of their the are they giving a
different answer and then is the is the
the better model is the worst model
really noisy or is the better model
sufficiently better so you know there's
this - is kind of like the key result
there if you want to go read up on it
but the beauty of this is that if you
look at this result right here
if you've ever done Ridge regression
this looks like l2 penalisation of a
different of a coefficient so if you can
figure out how to construct a feature
that will have this as the coefficient
then you just have to worry about
penalizing that coefficient so it turns
out that that's actually pretty easy to
do so there's a there's a form you can
either directly penalize it in an
objective function or it turns out
there's actually a simpler way which is
known as the control function approach
so who here has heard of the control
function approach or two-stage residual
inclusion okay who here has ever
estimated a first stage in an
instrumental variable so you estimate
this first stage which is the
probability that you show someone an ad
based on your randomization and maybe
some other stuff and then there's always
going to be a residual and so you're
going to estimate this residual which is
the difference between AD exposure and
predicted ad exposure and and then it
turns out that another way of estimating
the causal model the two stage least
squares instrumental variable model is
to just throw that in as a feature right
here so we just toss a feature in and it
turns out that the beta or the
coefficient on that feature is in fact
the exactly what we were looking for the
difference between the two models so it
controls for that and it's a really nice
so this is the key observation that
turns out that's exactly what we wanted
and so if you want to do the machine
learning version of this which is
instead of it being binary do I pick one
model or the other model let's just get
the model that is the convex combination
of these models that's that that
maximizes some like out of sample
prediction criteria all right so first
off like does this work well it's really
interesting to see that that in in
practice it actually does so here the
black line shows the prediction
predicted incremental effect dynamically
modeled in you know simulated data using
two using two stage least squares and
the red line shows what that effect is
if you use just the least squares model
so you can definitely see that it's
estimating it incorrectly as well this
gap looks small here that's just for
this example in practice those gap can
be orders of magnitude different
as as they found an eBay for example so
then the question is is as you get more
sample suppose you were to you know use
this convex combination using the
Hausman peasant penalisation or Houseman
causal correction will you eventually
converge to the right answer and the
answer is yes so what you'll see is that
as we increase the number of
observations we go from something that's
noisy and tends to be a little bit
closer to the noisier and but wrong or
sorry the less noisy but wrong Lee
scores answer we then can then
eventually converge to something that
lines up perfectly with two stage least
squares so like in practice what's that
what this means is that is that
sometimes you run an experiment and it
was low powered but it actually but the
but what you learned from the experiment
wasn't exactly what the treatment effect
was you learned the distribution of
where the treatment effect is not and so
you learned that it can't be bigger than
then the values that were covered by the
confidence interval and as a result that
actually imposes a restriction on the
least squares model that or the Ridge
model that then the Ridge model has to
it has to obey if you use if you add
these these control function features
and then tune them hyper parameter tune
them so like this was really what we
were looking for all along is how do we
use existing machine learning technology
where we can just throw in some magic
new features that will just suddenly
make our model causal and we do that by
adding randomization and then
constructing them so so in the end we
you know we we're trying to sort of
convex if I this space this is sort of
where machine learning lives you have a
regular eyes model or you have a fully
overfit model you know you maybe there's
regular eyes bandits where they're using
regression models to estimate band at
best response type functions and then in
econometrics we've done a lot of a lot
of things where we're just asking do we
want correlational or causal modeling
and really what we want to do is
probably something that's more in the
middle so we want to find something
that's sort of an optimal combination
that uses all of the experimental
variation that we have but then also
that recognizes that there's whole that
that are the most precise model is the
one that's able to use all the data
that's so I have been so thank you so
much for your time
[Applause]
questions
okay thanks a lot thanks so much and we
come back in one and a half hour and
flash it not so here so everybody is